Planning a business lunch with a client, coworker or boss?
Well, here are a few things to consider before you do.
You must know the restaurant.
If you're inviting a client for lunch...
...then it should definitely not be your first visit to the restaurant.
Be familiar with the seating.
Ask if it's possible to reserve a certain table away from the restroom, kitchens or front door.
Introduce yourself to the maitre d'.
Know him or her by name.
Know what the noise level's like at lunchtime.
You don't wanna have to shout or raise your voice when speaking about a sensitive deal.
Also, you don't want to take a vegetarian to a steak house.
If anything, you'll be the one making the sacrifice over the meal choices, not your client or boss.
Eat first, talk business after.
Have a little small talk.
Get to know each other.
Then dive into business before the meal or after dessert.
If your client wants to dive right in, by all means, do so.
A few things to remember about the table.
Pass the salt and pepper together; they are married.
Do not touch your nose, teeth, mouth, hair or head at the table.
Leave your handbag, keys, cell phone, notes, folders off the table.
If you're expecting a call relevant to your meeting, notify the table prior to starting lunch.
After using sugar, place the packets underneath the saucer...
...and don't tuck the napkin in your shirt.
It must always be placed on your lap.
Don't push your plate away or start stacking for the waitstaff.
If it's a large party, wait until five or six people have been served then you may begin.
If passing food, offer to your neighbor first.
And remember, enjoy yourself.
Thank you.
And always put grace first.